by the time it wrapped up it was agreed
that one of breaking bad's critical
strengths was its clear purpose making
it a rest here each without too many
plot holes dropped storylines or
extraneous scenes the acclaim 2013 final
episode of Breaking Bad decisively
concluded the story of Walter White's
but the fate of Jesse Pinkman was left
unknown now El Camino at Breaking Bad
movie is here to fill in the blanks
let's delve into the details and dig up
some Easter eggs and references you may
have missed and be warned spoilers are
ahead
El Camino begins with a flashback of
Jessie and Mike Ehrmantraut making
conversation about what they might
escape to if they ever ended up as
fugitives Mike is clear in his answer
Alaska the last frontier
by the time we catch up with Jesse
screaming down the road after the events
of Breaking Bad
it's clear he had escaped to the great
white north on his mind for a while but
first he has to take care of a few
things
Jesse's Dash for freedom is almost
immediately derailed by an army of
police officers alerted to the white
supremacist compound by the pounding
hellfire of bolts military-grade
swonsong seeing the red and blue
approaching Jesse swerves his car into a
driveway laying low with the lights off
as a police pass when they do he backs
out swiftly knocking over a mailbox the
mailbox hangs there holding in the
corner of the shots as Jesse flees the
address number 212 Phoenix is a 12th
episode of Breaking Bad second season or
episode 212 it's the episode when Jane
Jesse's then girlfriend dies it's a
turning point in Jesse's life that takes
him from a bad situation to true
prolonged misery considering that one of
el Caminos last scenes as a flashback to
Jesse and Jane this shouts out seems
suitable over the course of their time
on Breaking Bad skinny Pete's and Badger
proved themselves to be surprisingly
adorable they have surprising death from
skinny Pete's show-stopping piano skills
to the duo's abiding passion for sci-fi
in the season 5 breaking bad episode
Blood Money skinny Pete and badger have
an extended dialogue about Star Trek so
you're telling me every time Kirk went
near the transport he was killing
himself so over the whole series there's
like a hundred and forty seven Kirk's
please without background in minds it's
a real pleasure to see skinny piece
house so decked out in Star Trek
paraphernalia from starships on the
bookshelves to sci-fi inspire chairs in
front of the TV it's just another detail
to further flesh out the character we
thought we already knew Sharon Carr that
possibly addictive personalities can be
put toward interest
way more
than what you find at the end of a meth
pipe one of the more obscure Easter eggs
an El Camino doesn't require an
extensive knowledge of Breaking Bad or
at spin-off better call soul as much as
it relies on the viewers knowledge of
both show's creator Vince Gilligan the
charming and folksy showrunner has come
to inspire great loyalty in the people
that he works with but he also draws
similar praise from fans of his work
apart from the quality of his arts that
fandoms seems to be partly owed to the
fact that he's proven so willing to
engage audiences with callbacks and
references in El Camino one of those
nods is a lot more personal as Todd is
driving Jesse's his apartment to help
with an ambiguous but foreboding errand
the car passes by the intersection of
Holly Avenue and a Rose Lane Holly of
course was the name of Walter and Skyler
White's daughter the newborn whose
future security so motivated Walt's
twisted turned toward crime but Holly's
name was itself of reference to a
real-life figure Vince Gilligan's
longtime girlfriend Holly Rice censor
rose as a Spanish word for rice of all
people who would have thought the
Breaking Bad movie would spend so much
time on Todd one of the most loathsome
villains in a series are plenty to go
around
Todd returns an El Camino an extra large
fashioned with an extended flashback to
a dreadful weekend to Jesse spent in his
very weird company with his apartments
full of serial killer asks trophies
sparse decor and an actual dead body
Todd in El Camino comes off like a
combination between Jeffrey dormer and
that kid from st. elsewhere the most
perplexing objects in Todd's home can be
found at his collection of strange
apparently handmade snow globes well
there be innocuous decor for your
average kindergarten class they come off
as eerie in the context of Todd's
apartment the one held up by the faux
police officer just before a corner
Jesse makes himself known seems to show
a representation of Todd had locked in a
winter wonderland with Lydia the
high-powered operative in the global
meth scheme whom Todd developed an
unsettling fascination with she is shown
literally submerged in a giant teacup
frolicking while Todd watches what a
creep Breaking Bad loves us motifs
whether it's a one-eyed pink teddy bear
floating in the pool or the sky-blue
color of methamphetamine and so much
else another minor motif is dogs with
different characters being described as
Doug like relating to whatever is going
on in the story at the time Walt's lab
assistants Gail petaca is described
euphemistically as a dog who needs to be
put down by Jessie for being an
inconvenience it was just like
like a problem duck in season five the
unhinge revenge focused jesse becomes a
rabid dog
then after Walt flees Albuquerque a
single stray dog crosses the street on
the road behind him all alone
El Camino brings the dog motif back in
the dynamic between Jessi and Todd who
further proves us creepiness through the
way he treats his prisoner on multiple
occasions from the hair-combing to
remarks about keeping him better groomed
Todd reveals that he thinks of Jesse is
nothing more than a domesticated animal
it's deeply unsettling and speaks to the
deaths of abuse Jesse suffered during
his captivity
Jesse's escape from Albuquerque is an
arduous process and Jesse returns to his
parents home sneaking in with a hidden
key after luring them off the premises
he makes a beeline to it locked safe
working to retrieve some old guns for a
coming conflict as he makes his way
through the house he briefly pauses to
look up as he's standing over an ancient
crawlspace outlined in the floorboards
Jesse would have no way of knowing this
but a crawlspace like this one played
host to one of the most iconic shots in
the entire series and a low point for
Walt's in the episode crawlspace Walt
ended the hour literally sunken
underground the famous shots at intense
implications for the story to come
Walt it seemed was a dead man but
Jesse's not going to the crawlspace he's
going upstairs to find a tool for his
freedom
seeing Breaking Bad itself seems like a
given requirement for El Camino but what
viewers also have to be caught up on
better call Saul it's a good show but
one easy to sleep on the fourth season
isn't even on Netflix yet Vince Gilligan
was asked this very question in an
interview at The Hollywood Reporter
Wally had hopes of the dramatic States
will be clear enough to engage new
viewers he did agree that it's a better
movie for a fan of the series by all
means see Breaking Bad first better call
Saul not as much you can't say the man
lied to you there is indeed at least one
better call Saul referenced tucked away
in El Camino working to further
establish this fictional Albuquerque as
a living breathing place when Jesse
arrives for his final confrontation with
Jack and Todd's affiliates he has to
wait patiently as a group is entertained
by a group of strippers brought to the
location by a bodyguard named Clarence
this is the same Clarence who proved to
be uniquely unfit for bodyguard duties
during a previous encounter with Mike in
the season 1 episode pimento well he was
only referred to by his size rather than
his name
you want one
all right
when Breaking Bad first started it was
easy to see Walter White as a good man
with his back against the wall and Jesse
Pinkman says a moral necessary foil boy
did that flip by the end one of the ways
the audience learns of you jesse with
compassion was in the way he himself was
compassionate towards those around him
particularly children and animals jesse
even treated typically loathsome animals
like creepy looking insects kindly as
was shown in the season 2 episode
peekaboo that episode involved jesse
going off on his most arduous solo
mission to date fending off violent
far-gone meth heads as he attempted to
also do right by their solely neglected
child before that episode took off
though Jesse wild away the time by
letting a large black burger crawl onto
the back of his tattooed hand regarding
it with a smile as it crawled around his
fingers that skinny pea then immediately
moved to crush the bug seems to have
done little harm to their abiding
friendship el camino' makes a reference
to this scene as Jesse waits for the
strippers to leave before his final
attack on the welding company crew
letting a similar bug crawl onto his
head he regards it closely this time
keeping his thoughts private at least on
a housefly on Breaking Bad flies drive
you crazy
going into El Caminos mysterious release
you had to wonder are we going to see
any Walt in this thing while few really
thought the bullet riddled mr. Lamba
will be coming back to life it was
asking the questions of whether Bryan
Cranston will be back in the role in a
flashback and the bald cub the answer to
both questions turned out to be yes as
somewhat obvious yes in the case of the
bald cap from the clothes they're
wearing in their general demeanors Jesse
and while flashback scenes seem to take
place immediately after they found their
way back to civilization after being
stranded in the season two episode four
days out the scene features plenty of
fan service from Walt's absent mindedly
for getting Jesse graduated high school
- one last grandiose
during their discussion that Jessie and
won't get into the mildest of
disagreements about the value of
pineapple which Walt can take or leave
Jessie claims as good for you full of
bromine which Walter corrects to
bromelain well Jesse's attempt at trivia
is as Walt says not even close to being
right it is a reference of the chemical
element which forms a bra in Breaking
Bad's memorable title card when it was
first announced as the official title of
the mysterious shut-in secret Breaking
Bad movie the name el camino' struck
many as only deepening the mystery what
could it mean obviously the name El
Camino is most known as a classic
Chevrolet car truck hybrid with the hood
stripes on some models forming the basis
for a few of the breaking bad movies
promotional posters and specifically the
model of car Jesse uses to immediately
flee from the white supremacist come but
he doesn't hold on to the car for that
long instead it remains stowed at skinny
Pete's place as part of an improvised
plan to keep Jesse safe after the first
15 minutes it's barely in the movie
anymore
so what gives Breaking Bad was always a
series that enjoyed playing around with
titles when the titles of each of the
ominous plane crash flash-forward
episodes ultimately spelled out 737 down
over ABQ or how the last episodes named
Felina is both an anagram of finale and
the reference to the Marty Robbins song
that scores a critical part of the
episode translated into English el
camino means the way' which is a turn of
phrase is open to interpretation as
Jesse's original face he spends the
movie looking for a way out of his
predicament and the way forward in his
life perhaps sending up as Aaron Paul
told us so many years ago as a carpenter
living quietly in Alaska check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos but your
favorite shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel
and to the bail so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]
you